لم تؤتي العقوبات الغربيه على روسيا
ثمارها كما كان مرجوا منها على ما يبدو
وبدات الولايات المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي
التفكير جديا باجراءات تقيد موسكو اكثر
دبلوماسيو الاوروبي صرح بان مجموعه السبع
تدرس وضع حد اقصى لسعر النفط الروسي
المنقول بحرا يتراوح بين 65 دولار للبرميل
كمران اذ يناقش سفراء من دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي البالغ عددها 27 دوله هذا
الاقتراح بهدف التوصل لموقف المشترك في
نهايات الامر ومن المقرر ان تبدا مجموعه
السبع والاتحاد الاوروبي في الخامس من
ديسمبر بتطبيق الحد الاقصى للسعر على
صادرات النفط الروسي المنقوله بحران
لمعاقبه موسكو علشانها حربا على اوكرانيا
مسؤول كبير في وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه
قال ان سقف اسعار صادرات النفط الروسيه
سيتعدل على الارجح بضع مرات في السنه وليس
بشكل شهري الهدف الاساس من الخطوه تقليل
عائده النفط لاله الحرب الروسيه مع الحفاظ
على تدفق الخام الى الاسواق العالميه ومنع
ارتفاع الاسعار من المقرر ان يبدا التطبيق
الحد الاقصى لصادرات المنتجات النفطيه
الروسيه في الخامس من فبراير المقبل لكن
للرئيس الروسي راي ايضا
[موسيقى]
اذا كانت اسعار النفط من روسيا او دول
اخرى محدوده وتم وضعه حدود سعريه مصنعه
فسيؤدي ذلك حتما الى تفاقم مناخ الاستثمار
في قطاع الطاقه العالميه ومن ثم سيؤدي الى
نقص عالميا في موارد الطاقه وسترتفع
تكلفتها وهذا اكرر سيصيب الدول الفقيره
منخفاض المخزون الاستراتيجي الامريكي ثم
انخفضت باكثر من دولار بعد ذلك تقول وزيره
الخزانه الامريكيه جانين والتي دفعت
باتجاه الخطوه بشده ان الهدف من الخطه هو
تقليص عائلتي صادرات الطاقه الروسيه مع
تجنب ارتفاع اسعار النفط لكن اوروبا تعاني
وتواجه ازمه ارتفاع الاسعار وازمه طاقه
خانقه اخرج التظاهرات غاضبه في شوارع مدن
اوروبيه
ستحضر مجموعه السبع والاتحاد الاوروبي
واستراليا تقديمها الخدمات البحريه لشحنات
النفط الروسيه ما لم يتم بيعه النفط باقل
من سقف السعر لكنها خطه وجهه وعقبه فلا
تزال المحادثات بشان الحد الاقصى مثيره
للجدل الذي يدعو عدد من البلدان بما في
ذلك بولندا ولتانيا الى تحديد سقف اقل
كثير حول سعر الانتاج
روسيا كانت هددت بوقف البيع للدول التي
تلتزم بسعر السقف لكنه واشنطن قللت من
اهميه التهديدات الروسيه لكون موسكو لا
تستطيع ان تتوقف عن بيع نفطها على الاقل
لحلفائها تحديدا الهند والصين وقبل ان
تبدا الخطوه بدات الاستثناءات اذ قررت
وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه استثناء النفط من
مشروع الطاقه الروسيه اثنين المتجه الى
اليابان من السقف السعري وكاله انباء
انباء كيودو اليابانيه افادت بان طوكيو
وشركات تجاريه اليابانيه ستحتفظ بحصص في
مشروع خلين اثنين الذي تعتبره الحكومه
مصدرا مهما لامدادات الطاقه للبلد الفقير
بالموارد اذ ان واردات النفط الروسيه شكلت
حوالي ثلاثه فاصل سته بالمئه من اجمالي
الواردات اليابانيه العام الماضي
[موسيقى]